as dealing with some alcoholism issues I
thought she would be incredible for some
um for someone who deserved her and I
didn't feel like I was that person Jason
Ritter in tears over wife Melanie
lynskey sorry during a recent episode of
The Drew Barrymore show the actor opens
up about the early days of their
relationship I knew how incredible
Melanie was early on it's not as cute of
a story as as you would like to think it
was messy and um interesting and weird
and I thought she would be incredible
for some
um for someone who deserved her
basically
um and I didn't feel like I was that
person and he says while things didn't
start off easy overcoming his struggles
with alcoholism made them stronger it
was only after like
maybe a year into not drinking where I
started to go oh maybe I maybe I can
promise some things to someone else
maybe I can be this person it's been
like a slow burn so it was so I knew
that she was incredible it was it was
working on myself enough to feel like
maybe maybe I could be the one for her
too
um sorry but Jason wasn't the only one
getting choked up sorry
you looked so hard he did so much work
on himself I'm so proud of him
sorry sorry
it's gonna get more fun
over the years the two have proved time
and time again their hashtag couple
goals I feel so fortunate I don't have
anything to complain about Jason
is the greatest human being last year
when speaking with E.T Melanie got
emotional over her hubby it feels like
sorry I honestly feel like I won the
lottery of the greatest husband he's
such a good dad he loves me he makes me
feel beautiful no matter what
he's he's a good good person and he's so
cute
you guys as a couple people freak out
they love you so much are you receiving
the love or is this news to you
love yeah yeah people are very people
are very supportive yeah yeah we've been
to stay together yeah or I mean I'm
hoping so
[Music]